Kim starts off this hour in Phoenix
Arizona hi Kim how are you I'm good a
little nervous but I'm happy to be
talking to you thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure
how can I help my husband and I moved
here to Phoenix in 2009 and we're
fortunate enough to buy a home and a
short sale and so today the value of our
home we have an equity of approximately
180,000 which is great we have $25 $25
$25,000 in credit card debt we also have
a car loan of 18,000 my husband has been
off work for the last five months and
has just recently gone back fortunately
we had some money in the bank to whether
us through that but we also accrued some
of that credit card debt and he's 52 I'm
63 and so he still has a lot of working
years ahead of him and I'm trying to
determine do we should we sell our home
and go rent until we figure out what
other size of home we need or want to
have I'm wondering right here $1,300 a
month
what is your take home pay now that he's
back to work monthly monthly between
eight and nine thousand okay do you like
the house I like the house I'm not
married to the house it's five bedrooms
three bath pool I'm home alone by myself
a lot it's a lot for me to maintain
we're empty nesters obviously and you
know I could probably use a smaller
house okay in an ideal world but you
could look you could live in a smaller
house but it's not because of I mean
your payment is not killing you
no it is not into the stress of this
debt yeah and you said you said you are
how old I'm 63 63 and he is 52 too
okay good okay no I think you guys just
worked the baby steps you're making a
lot of money and you know if you want to
get rid of that real fast saw a car I
want to sell the house but but if you
want to work your way through it you can
work your way through it the rule of
thumb we use on cars is can you be
debt-free except the house in two years
your answer is yes you could pay off
both of these debts eighteen and
twenty-five and two years making the
kind of money y'all make and is your
house I mean income and is the cars that
you own anything with cars and motors
and wheels totaled up equal more than
half your annual income because then you
have too much invested in things going
down in value and you don't have that
unless you unless your other car is uber
expensive well the car payment itself
yes no no no no what value the value of
the car twenty five thousand and the
other car is worth what we have but the
other one is paid for but it's wrong it
was it's it's worth what mm yeah okay so
you have less than $30,000 worth of cars
and you know and you guys are making a
hundred and forty thousand dollars a
year well he makes about a hundred out
well between a hundred thousand he works
away from home and a seasonal job so he
is not employed every single month of
the year and that's part of my fear is
that no trying to pay all these off plus
build up the savings again for when he's
not working I'm well you know that he's
not gonna be working right yeah so we
got a plan for that that has to be in
the monthly budget you have to set aside
money to get ready for winter
they were squirreling money away we call
it in the South the squirrels put nuts
in the nest in the summer right because
winter is coming and so you say how many
months of income do you need to cover
next year probably three okay let's get
that saved immediately before we do
anything else and then and then we'll
start the baby steps okay I think I
think I'm probably really thinking about
selling this car
that's a doable thing I was I just I was
thinking is like the most easy thing to
do the easiest thing to sell a lot
easier selling a house it's a lot less
impact on the family a lot less impact
or anything else it's okay if you want
to sell your house and move down I don't
mind here but the financial situation
you're in does not require it okay all
right I think I just needed somebody
with some logic instead of the emotional
side of everything
well you're scared because you guys got
knocked in the mouth last year yeah that
makes you a human being to be scared
about that that doesn't make you bad I
mean that that's a normal human reaction
so it's smart to be you know very aware
right now danger danger you know so
let's set the three months aside and
let's start working a debt snowball cut
up all the credit cards chop them up you
guys can talk about the car you can talk
about the house I don't care if you sell
you the one of them doesn't matter to me
as long as we get about the business of
getting them paid off if you want to
move down in-house into something a
little smaller and a little more
manageable even if it was the same price
range I'm okay with that just because
you want to okay I wouldn't move up in
house but your house payment is not
killing you no it's not the house
payment you know it's just you know when
you have a home it's the maintenance so
I know that we're going to need air
conditioning I know that we're going to
need to paint it due to the HOA and all
those things so all those things on top
of trying really hard to bank with
savings again because we have nothing
left in savings anymore well I think you
get three months built back up and
that's not really an emergency fund
that's Christmas at your Christmas
account for your three months Christmas
is going to be in December you got a
plan for it you have three months you're
going to be off you got a plan for it
and then and then we start our baby
steps and you have another thousand
dollars baby step one and then you start
paying off these credit cards and then
you pay off this car and or sell the car
and move down and then your debt free
everything but the house and then let's
kind of see how the house feels then
that's a good way of looking I did check
with the tax guy and he's
he would sell the house and fund an IRA
account because we have absolutely no
money in retirement funds and anything
much guys should not do financial
planning
they suck at it all right little calmer
right now I appreciate your advice and I
feel like I can take a deep breath and
yeah I'm okay I'm okay I think you might
sell this house
to accelerate your retirement planning
and that kind of stuff and to get in the
house you kind of like more or less
worried about maintenance and that kind
of junk don't know pool to keep up and
all that kind of stuff
I mean you might sell it but I think
you'll make a better decision about
whether to sell it once your debt free
and have three months in the bank all
right thank you so very much for your
time I appreciate it honor to talk to
you thank you for calling in